Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
A tangle pattern is a beautiful, intervowen
tapestry of basic stroke patterns, like dots,
straight lines, and simple curves.
If we look at some of these works, we see
that many of these are highly structured,
and maybe, we could automatically create such
beautiful structures with a computer.
And, now, hold on to your papers, because
this piece of work is about generating tangle
patterns with grammars.
Okay, now, stop right there.
How on Earth do grammars have anything to
do with computer graphics or tangle patterns?
The idea of this sounds as outlandish as it
gets.
Grammars are a set of rules that tell us how
to build up a structure, such as a sentence
properly from small elements, like nouns,
adjectives, pronouns, and so on.
Math nerds also study grammars extensively
and set up rules that enforce that every mathematical
expression satisfies a number of desirable
constraints.
It's not a surprise that when mathematicians
talk about grammars, they will use these mathematical
hieroglyphs like the ones you see on the screen.
It is a beautiful subfield of mathematics
that I have studied myself before, and am
still hooked.
Especially given the fact that from grammars,
we can build not only sentences, but buildings.
For instance, a shape grammar for buildings
can describe rules like a wall can contain
several windows, below a window goes a window
sill, one wall may have at most two doors
attached, and so on.
My friend Martin Ilcik is working on defining
such shape grammars for buildings, and using
these grammars, he can generate a huge amount
of different skyscrapers, facades, and all
kinds of cool buildings.
In this piece of work, we start out with an
input shape, subdivide it into multiple other
shapes, assign these smaller shapes into groups.
And the final tangle is obtained by choosing
patterns and assigning them to all of these
groups.
This yields a very expressive, powerful, tool
that anyone can use to create beautiful tangle
patterns.
And all this, through the power of grammars.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!